it was announced today that there was a
change in the leadership at krispy kreme
donuts
uh yeah it's a big company apparently
stephen cooper will no longer be the ceo
and former
crafts foods divisional chief daryl
brewster is stepping in to replace him
wait
wait wait wait wait conan did you just
say daryl rooster's gonna be running
krispy kreme donuts
instead of stephen cooper yeah yeah
that's right no no man that can't be
happening
daryl brewster's running krispy kreme
donuts
there's no reason to live where's my
kayak
where's my kayak
daryl brewster is ruining christmas
dreams
oh my god that poor guy oh
[Applause]
all right well that's that's great i'm
glad you're okay unfortunately uh
your seat has already been filled yeah
but uh if you want there's still room in
the back
sit in the back with those people those
are the worst seats in the house man
if i have to sit back there there's no
reason to live
no reason to live where's my bicycle
where's my bicycle
oh my god i never knew there was an iron
suspension bridge
outside our popcorn center
and i've been here a long time i should
look around more while my apologies to
the viewers who had the witnesses
okay now you know what i'm sorry sir
you're just gonna have to i'm sorry but
you have to stop pretending to kill
yourself
it's a big waste of time and it's
distracting people from the show
i can't pretend to kill myself anymore
i'm sorry no you can't i can't pretend
to kill myself there's no reason
oh god where's my train
where's my foot
take me away
did you say 60.5 because i thought the
institute for supply management's index
for non-manufacturing business activity
was at 59.0
no no it's interesting analysts
predicted it would be 59.00
but it's actually at 60.5 oh no no no
this can't be i thought it was 59.0
there's no reason to live there's no
reason where's my kayak
no reason
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now everyone said i know that was
upsetting but just relax
cause we've done this before and usually
by this time that guy he runs down the
stairs behind the studio
and he comes through those doors in a
kayak to say he nailed his landing he's
fine he's not hurt
and uh well this is weird he hasn't
shown up yet
i'm a little worried now i i think
something must have happened this time
something did happen conan something
very bad
hi i'm dr ron werling with km's
tams yeah see kayak accident emergency
medical squad chaos
i'm afraid that guy didn't make it
that's
horrible yes yes he will be missed
no no no no your costume is horrible
it's obvious you're the same guy who
just got into the kayak you didn't fool
anybody
i didn't fool anybody it's ridiculous
there's no reason to live
where's my skateboard
[Applause]
that's terrible that was such a long
fall i have to say
i don't know if he could have survived
that he didn't conan
hi i'm don whirling from spoiler
spadhua yes the skateboard accidental
death undertaker's association
we just buried that guy
i have three things to say right now one
we know it's still you you idiot two
this is the worst sketch i've ever been
a part of
and three this is the biggest waste of
time in the history of television
biggest waste of time there's no reason
to live
where are my balloons
[Applause]
i have to be honest with you may is my
favorite month to be in chicago because
during the month of may this is
interesting
the average temperature is 59 and there
are only 10
partly cloudy days in the month which i
think is nice wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
did you say there's 10 partly cloudy
days because i thought it was nine
partly cloudy days
and i'm a total idiot and there's no
reason to live
there's no man to live
i am uh folks i am so sorry you all had
to witness that incredible tragedy
it's okay it's okay
wait a minute wait a minute you fell
down a mountain
and then you came back at a higher
elevation
that's idiotic that defies the laws of
physics
it defies the laws of physics oh god
there's no reason to live
where's my 10-speed bicycle
[Applause]
reason i wanted these shows to be
special i'm really sorry you all had to
see that that's too bad that's okay
i did an x-game style now wait a minute
who cares falling off a mountain falling
off a bridge all of this has nothing to
do with chicago
nothing to do with chicago well where's
the car i parked in marina towers
[Music]
franklin all right then
he's finally dead